[Musique]
comme chaque année au mois d'octobre le
département de La Réunion vous ouvre les
portes de son patrimoine naturel à
l'occasion des rendez-vous nature du 8
au 23 octobre les Réunionnais sont
invitées à s'émerveiller de la beauté et
de la diversité de ces paysages mais
aussi de sa faune et de sa flore le
programme de cette 18e édition a été
dévoilée cette semaine au domaine
Fleurier par le président du département
en présence des partenaires chaque année
le département vous propose proposerai
de naze réunionnais devenir à la
rencontre de cette belle nature qui nous
entoure vous savez que nous portons la
gestion des espaces naturels sensibles
de la Réunion il y en a partout je vous
invite à venir découvrir ces espaces
naturels sensibles qui sont aménagés où
nous protégeons la nature nous
préservons la biodiversité mais là où
nous offrons aussi tous nos concitoyens
des espaces de découverte de randonnées
à l'occasion de ces rendez-vous nature
le département et ses partenaires vous
invite à célébrer l'anniversaire des 30
ans des espaces naturels sensibles de
l'île 30 ans
le département a démarré tous ces
projets d'aménagement de protection des
espaces naturels il y a 30 ans et
beaucoup de chemin ont été parcourus des
espaces qui ont été parfois dégradés qui
sont aujourd'hui réhabiliter nos agents
ont bien travaillé je tiens les
remercier je remercie aussi tous les
partenaires qui sont associés avec nous
sur ces opérations rendez-vous nature et
qui tout au long de l'année
entretiennent les sites durant deux
semaines le public est amené à découvrir
une trentaine d'espaces naturels comme
le domaine Fleurier la superficie alors
c'est deux entités sur de notoriées en
tout et pour tout 97 hectares 97
hectares et sur 197 hectares il y a que
quatre hectares qui sont en espace entre
guillemets verts dédié au pique-nique
alors moi je suis conservatoire de
métier il y a un fort intérêt écologique
derrière ce site de pique-nique et c'est
là avec les gens qu'on va découvrir ça
on va découvrir donc ce qui fait c'est
pas que leur de pique-nique qu'est-ce
qu'il y a au-delà de leur pique-nique
ici par exemple des espèces en 2000
qu'on retrouve ici il y a bois de
Colette bois d'Arnet bois de joli coeur
en faune on va retrouver donc le tech le
zoologue on peut le retrouver sous blanc
Zoover au menu de cette 18e édition des
Rendez-vous nature près de 200 visites
guidées et animations pédagogiques
gratuites pour petits et grands aux
quatre coins de l'île découvrez tout le
programme sur département 9 7 4 fr
[Musique]